[Music]
things before we actually get started
the first one raise your hand if you
don't want to be in a selfie with me and
you lot cool I'm gonna take that right
now well in the form that's gone on
Twitter later
raise your hand if you really don't want
me to post on Twitter it's okay you can
say so right okay cool
the second thing I have a lot of these
ducks with me if you want one come grab
one close enough like I mean I have a
lot they're great for pairing because
unlike a real pair when you get annoyed
you can just hit them that they well and
also they don't talk back as much and
they let you code all the time so
they're much better than a real pair so
my third point I'd like questions but I
want I and I want to encourage you to
ask questions throughout the talk so I
just I have a couple of little rules to
make this go a bit more fluid if you
have a question raise your hand I might
do this which just means give me a
minute I'll get to the end of what like
my point and then I'm gonna come to you
right because maybe I'm going to address
your question in the next two seconds in
which case you know it'll probably be
easier that way and I see one more thing
I am a native English speaker which
means I will probably speak too fast at
some point do this it will tell me to
slow down
okay I'll be really helpful
I can speak very slow and I won't do
that okay let's get started
um what does it mean to be human
well we call said that I don't speak
French so I'm not going to try and read
that but you know he said I don't feel
that it is necessary to know exactly
what I am the main interest in life and
work is to become someone else that you
were not in the beginning Descartes said
something much simpler that kinda has
the same effect I think therefore I am
and I really thought I would be the
first person to mention that for today
but Dad in half and we are our choices
I'm really I'm not gonna read the French
you'll you'll be embarrassed I'll be
embarrassed well it's better for
everyone if I just read the translation
basically humans are not very much like
machines right humans are perceptive we
make assumptions we derive information
from context machines do what they are
told so in this talk I'm going to show
you three experiments and kind of a
potential future that we are imagining
I'm going to focus the first half on
talking about why this is not as true as
we might imagine and the second half on
why it doesn't matter
so I'm accident you've only seen the
first half of this talk so you know the
second I should still be interesting so
humans are awful at programming for all
the above reasons right I'll give you an
example who remembers left pad so left
hat is a infamous library that does one
very useful thing in JavaScript it pads
things to the left so if I give it 30
seven five five digits and pad with zero
so i get zero zero zero three seven this
is the implementation
left pad you don't have to read it but
it's actually you know more complex than
I would have thought and I've removed a
bunch of stuff because well there's just
a cash stuff cash thing and I want to
show you one commit that came in at one
point which was this one there are 60
commits in left pad or just over 60 and
this one converts your value that you
give it to a string because if you give
it a number like 37 well it doesn't know
how to pad that but it does know how to
pad the string 37
so this converts it to a string can you
guess what the next commit is I'll show
you it's this one it will happen two
minutes later
so rather than converting it to a string
before we asked for a lens we convert it
to a string with before because it turns
out asking for a lens of a number not
very helpful so I hate to tell you this
but computers are way better
finding these kinds of bugs than humans
are it's not the there's you know humans
are bad reasoning about things but
rather we just don't bother most of the
time and you know that makes sense
because we have tools to do the
reasoning for us like a type checker a
good type checker may have caught this
except a JavaScript white checker
wouldn't because well
javascript is a permissive language and
it turns out you can add a length
property to basically anything so sure
it probably has a length property even a
type checker wouldn't catch it unless
you gave it additional information right
um but dynamic languages have this have
a power right it's really valuable to be
able to write first and think later not
always but sometimes that's exactly what
I need I need to try something to see if
it works and then reason about why it
works after I already understand just a
little bit more with that power comes
responsibility you know the
responsibility now you are responsible
for making sure your code makes sense
not your compiler not your type checker
you have linters in JavaScript but you
know they're half-baked because well
anything could be anything
OOP I don't want that responsibility
personally because I'm not a machine so
I want to talk a bit about what your
machine can do for you so okay I have a
quiz what other types of the parameters
to this function Scheldt say again sorry
yeah it could be anything
it's probably like like we thought we I
mean you and I know it's a number but
there could be anything and the caller
doesn't necessarily know that right I
mean here's the same function different
names same function but now it's very
obvious to me that their strings I think
and this is a problem because again in
JavaScript did you know that the empty
object plus the empty array is 0 I
learnt this last year because I was
trying things out there's a great talk
by someone called Gary Bernhardt called
what w80
which elaborates on this in detail if
you're interested oh I lost the duck I
want to show you something this is an ml
based type inference tool that we built
who can read this who can't read this
wave
I saw someone put their glasses on on
the back so I'm gonna zoom in a little
bit
hopefully that is a little bit readable
so I give this type checker which is
which uses some type information from a
typical type checker and then kind of
does its own thing to ask what this
types are it is 87 percent confident
that x and y are numbers right so this
type checker we built us in house a
company I helped run called proto and
it's using graph modeling to
you have represent the data like the
code just not as often as we think of
these things as text right we look at
code and go okay yeah function add XY
like these are but it's actually an
abstract syntax tree right that's what
we're dealing with we deal with tree
structures we just happen to represent
them as these kind of grids of text and
that's cool but it doesn't give us the
information we need half the time and
this is why you know your actual type
checker especially if you deal with a
statically typed language if you write
Java or etc then your type checker like
it's part of the compiler and it will
compile to a syntax tree before its eyes
tries to type check and that's true of
any other type checker but when machine
learning most of this stuff has been
limited to text because most advances in
machine learning have been done in
things like NLP natural language
processing not neuro linguistic
programming that would be really cool if
machines could do that and slightly
terrifying I think that we think that's
the plot of Terminator but they focus on
things like natural language processing
which is why translation engines are
really good now I know because I managed
to order food in a French restaurant and
they didn't laugh at me for at least
three seconds and images that's the
other thing we're very good at right but
graphs on you there's a lot of research
going on we are contributing lots of
other organizations academia
contributing to the field of research
that is graph based machine learning and
this is about as good as we can get
right now you know we can tell that it's
a number you notice that there's a
limited set of types we can deal with
object string function number undefined
array boolean null or any fortunately
never predicts any so release going
somewhere I want to show you something
so if I change this
- can't they function now it's pretty
certain that those are strings right and
this is really helpful not instead of
your typical logic based type checker
but as well as right because it can make
inferences that logic can't because if I
think these are strings we can then go
and add those types in later and then
that the logic base types I could
propagate them outlets or even propagate
them out using machine learning right it
can make assumptions of the sorts that
you and I can but a machine typically
can't I want to show you something else
this is much simpler right you can read
that right what does it do hmm nothing
yeah true but you know what it's
supposed to do you could I think if I
asked every single person in this room
to fix this make it work unless you were
trolling you would fix it in exactly the
same way right but a machine can't do it
right so we haven't we can project we're
just messing around and this is based on
an or P techniques okay now I need to
zoom out again all right you can just
about read that so giving the same
information to a tool we call auto fix
which I'm really hoping will be in avid
to plug in sometime soon and we'll just
go and add that bracket back in and it's
trained on a lot of data about what code
is supposed to look like and it can
predict there usually if something is
following a value as if that if there's
a square bracket somewhere in the
statement and if there isn't a closing
square bracket it probably goes before
the semicolon so it makes that guess and
it puts it up and we're very proud of it
because it almost never gets it wrong
often it will do nothing but it almost
never gets it wrong which is kind of
where I want it to be I would rather the
tool did nothing than the wrong thing so
we're very happy about that the point is
that it turns out computers can make
these kinds of judgments if we give them
enough information they need a lot more
than you all right right a human can
learn a new programming language and
understand the syntax with probably a
few files worth of information you can
understand roughly what this thing is
going to do especially if it looks
similar to one you've seen before but
even if I showed you some house call
code you'd probably figure out that okay
the brackets have to match up pretty
quickly it's not so true with
programming it was computers but you
know they do figure out eventually
it just takes approximately a hundred
thousand to a million files to train
them so I care a lot about this one
right probably more than I should
because I really really hate this kind
of error I really hate that when I copy
something from one array into another
array and I haven't put a comma in
between the tool just yelled at me I
feel like it's slapping me on the wrist
and I feel like I'm being judged by my
own technology and this is very
upsetting to me right when I pair with a
human being and they just you know put a
comment in when I didn't see or they
just nudge me and go hey you forgot a
test case there they're usually very
gentle at least ones I like pairing with
but when I when I'm pairing with my
compiler it just shouts at me is like
wrong I don't know what to do with this
you are wrong and that happens about a
thousand times a day if I'm spending the
whole day programming and it's kind of
upsetting it
I want my tools to work with me not
against me I I mean it's nice that they
told me when I'm wrong I lost some ducks
but it's it would be nicer if they at
least were nice about it and like they
were gentle about it and sometimes just
did it because well come on there's only
one thing you can't do here just do it
please
so what I'm asking you to do is to be
dissatisfied I don't want what we have
now to be the end of it right
compilers have basically stayed the same
for
thirty years maybe 40
they are cleverer but they're not more
useful they take your code they turn it
into bits and bytes and machine language
and byte code and things like that but I
can't read but you know the computer can
that's it I wanted to go further before
I move on any questions
it's okay you don't have to have
questions I'll be here all day I want to
talk to you about symbiosis because we
learnt something in the last year or so
these like we spent a lot of time being
a research company and it was a lot of
fun we got to make cool stuff most of
which I don't understand because I do
the front-end and and the accounting and
some of the legal stuff and other stuff
that no one wants to do but we realized
something which was the software is like
it doesn't understand everything about
what it is to be a programmer so we
started exploring I want to show you
something again zoom until we can see it
this is left pads the actual
implementation and I put at the bottom
three uses of left pad that are actually
in the documentation this is how it
should work right and what it says I
realized that the syntax highlighting is
making this very hard to read so I'm
just going to read it out for you so if
I left pad the string foo to five I
should get space space F oh if I left
pad one two two two two characters using
the padding character of zero I should
get zero one and if I left pad 17 to
five characters with zero this time the
integer zero not the character zero or
the number because JavaScript doesn't
have integers we'll talk about that
later
I should get zero zero zero one seven
but I introduced a bug in this so
actually what I get is foo is correct I
get and it doesn't pad the numbers we've
built this tool it's called Alfie as an
experiment because we were bored in
November and we really really wanted
something that we would enjoy using we
actually built this for advent of code
which is for those of you who don't know
a fairly popular programming competition
that happens in December every year and
we wanted people to we wanted to want to
make it easier for people to get started
programming with algorithmic challenges
you know maybe you're practicing for a
job interview maybe you're doing some
cutters whatever it is I you know if you
have to start setting up an environment
it's painful so we built a thing that's
kind of fun for us and it was really
important we based this on a talk by
Brett Victor called inventing on
principle if you haven't seen it I
recommend it if you have seen it I
recommend it a second time where we
question the need for a debugger because
a debugger is developer asking questions
off the software when something usually
when something has gone wrong or when
they need to verify there something's
gone right but what if you could just
have all the information straight away
so given the stuff on the right can
someone tell me where the bug is
oh you're all so shy go on line 16 yeah
and so we can see that right the data
tells us that we're getting nan or not a
number sorry I should probably repeat
what you said if some people might have
heard it it's on line 16 and we are
asking for the length or something that
is a number exactly the by they showed
you earlier right so if I were to say
put the fix in you can see immediately
that the data is updated like the values
that go through the system are updated
to see the correct thing the length of
one is one the length of 17 is
apparently three of the length of the
sorry 5 minus 2 is 3 that 5 minus 2 is 3
right ok call my software works sorry
I'm really bad at Matt's listen why I
make tools to do that for me like why am
I doing this this is what machines are
for the this is kind of I don't know
this is the feedback I always want from
my tooling but I can't always have it
it's easy for algorithms right because
you're working with usually with numbers
and strings and things where you don't
have gigantic data structures that have
to go over message keys it's slightly
harder for you know real-world
programming environments but this is
what I want from everything I want it to
just tell me what's wrong and you know
as a human you can look at you know the
broken implementation you just go back
to that and you know people are really
good at pattern recognition so your eyes
just jump to the now and if you've ever
seen it before your eyes just go bump
there's the bug because you can see that
there's a problems I bet you when you
see a null in a lot in a giant log your
eyes just flash to it right we're really
really good at pattern recognition
Daniel Kahneman calls this system one in
his book Thinking Fast and Slow or
something related to it anyway I think
system one's a little bit deeper than
that but basically we work on instinct
most of the time it's really effective
it's very efficient and it gets us where
we need to be most of the time and
computers don't really have that
instinct so while we can train machines
to be instinctual about certain things
by putting a square bracket it's hard it
takes a long time to figure out how to
do that but if you can give all the data
to someone intelligent well they had
like they have the information they
could do something useful with her right
and this symbiosis between human and
machine it turns out is really powerful
you know contrary to popular belief in
1997 when deep blue beat Garry Kasparov
in chess it wasn't actually the best
chess player in the world because the
best chess players were not humans or
machines but humans who were using
machines to get a competitive advantage
they could be a computer a hundred times
out of 100 we can make smart decisions
if we just have the information that we
need right we're good at that that's
kind of how we are built that's why
humans can do all the things we do I
wanted to highlight some principles of
the agile manifesto not the valley is
not the lot of four things although the
first one's very interesting at least in
this context I just pulled out a few
phrases early in continuous delivery
changing requirements deliver frequently
work together daily face-to-face
conversation continuous attention
enhances agility the team reflects when
I look at these and I boil them down
what I really see is that the only thing
that matters is feedback more feedback
fewer problems right
I can get stuff done faster and if I can
get stuff done faster it's not just that
I can fix the bug quicker but the odds
of the bug emerging in the first place
are lower right so we really enjoyed
building Alfea but we stopped in
December right because while it was very
interesting for us and we learnt loads
especially about how to do a lot of
introspection in code it's not something
we can go to any one of you and say hey
use this on your codebase because well
you have to use our editor and you have
to do everything in one file and you
know there is no version control and how
do you ship here you get the idea but we
had a real problem ourselves in building
Elfi partially which is we wanted this
kind of introspection and information
not just in the algorithms that we use
but also in the components that we use
so I want to introduce a new project we
release this for the first time
yesterday it is buggy as hell it's been
in development for less than a month
there have been two people working on it
and we're very very very proud of what
we've done so far and we call it Snoopy
because we really like dogs I should
have put a picture in here about office
dog I'll find one for you later my
colleague Tom who helps thoughts on the
company has the most beautiful food all
cocker spaniel hybrid and it's just it
makes go into the office every day was
it so we really like dogs we call this
one Snoopy because frankly we want you
to be lazy
this is Snoopy it is very bare-bones
please don't judge our UI but we we use
it right now to build itself right I'm
going to show you a very simple to do
application you know you get the idea
right this is a real application that I
can run separately but it's I'm just
rendering the app component the top
level component for those of you who
don't know how react works this is all
based on react it's a declarative
language that looks a bit like HTML that
allows you to embed JavaScript wherever
you like so you have this nice hybrid of
imperative stuff when you need to get
stuff done and manage state and mostly
declarative for actually rendering the
components if you've used Elm it's the
same except with more syntax you know
it's what you expect the important thing
here is fun rendering issues I told you
it as buggy and like this one is my
fault cuz I start this demo yesterday if
I want to work on a component if I want
to change things I need to be able to
see it not just in one state but in
every single possible state right so
when I'm working on the list of tasks in
my simple to do this application I don't
want to just know what the list looks
like with a bunch of stuff in it but
what it looks like with nothing in it
what it looks like when some stuff is
done what it looks like when I'm halfway
through editing something and I want to
pre share it's good when you get
continuous feedback from your audience
right now imagine if your compiler gave
you the same thing and when I change
stuff and I want to see if I can get
this going let's see what happens okay
this is gonna be fun I'm gonna do some
live coding that I totally didn't
prepare for let's see what happens
so when I for example accidentally flip
the done variable I should a little bit
of luck no oh yeah there we go so it
crosses off the wrong things right
because what I'm supposed to see is the
checkbox is checked and it's crossed out
or later there we go
this is because I'm running on a four
year old MacBook so it's a very very
simple example I don't mean to brag
about this thing but we're very proud of
it and I'll tell you why I really really
hate making infrastructure decisions and
it turns out when you start a JavaScript
projects of any sort especially one with
front-end stuff you have to configure
your bundler which is usually webpack
and has infinite configuration you have
to decide which plugins you use you even
have to choose which variant of the
language you want to use we use
typescript on other people don't this is
really painful right and then you have
to decide how you're going to write your
tests you have to decide how you're
going to test your UI and all of these
things boil down to what we call
integration fatigue the idea that you
spend way more time working on your
infrastructure and by infrastructure I
really mean anything that is not your
domain anything that is not about your
business you so you spend way more time
working on that than you do actually
solving business problems so this is the
present right you see one thing at a
time when you're looking at your app you
have to debug your code you have to
figure out how your data in your
database got that way by reading commits
about us you know in which you changed
your SQL if the right UI tests which
take pictures not off
the actual UI but often you know the
HTML that was rendered or something like
it and you have to ship it to your
customers and wait weeks to see if it
actually works on up
and this is kind of how I imagine the
future we're just taking care of the
first thing right now but we're working
on the rest as fast as we can I want to
see everything at once not just even
this component but how is this component
used in every single context that's used
in every single state so that it can be
in I want to see a history if ever how
everything got that way I have no idea
why we don't just have a vent sourcing
by default for free in every single new
project we ever write I totally want it
together because I really need to know
not just what might the state of my
system is but what it was and how it how
it was derived I have no idea why we
write UI tests because UI is weird right
when I write a unit test for a piece of
business logic or even some
infrastructure usually there is a right
answer
whereas with UI is usually this feels
right and I don't know how to test for
feeling but what I do know is that
humans are really good at it and so I
don't need the machine to know what
feels right I just need to give the
human the information as fast as
possible and let them make a judgment
call and instead of waiting weeks to
find out whether something works I
really want you to be able to get
feedback at any moment just by sending a
link someone else and I've been talking
about front-end because that's what we
care about right now but this should
apply to anything right like if you use
cucumber I would love it if you could
just get feedback on your specification
immediately like if you use like if you
send your data over message queues it
should be easy to understand whether
your customers your consumers are
getting the data and the format they
expect of the quality they expect
I just have one request from you when
pushing towards the future it turns out
the analyzing software and trying to
derive it infrastructure for free is so
much easier if your code is offer higher
quality there's a paper call on the
naturalness of buggy code which explains
that good code looks like other good
code but bad code but codes that is
buggy codes that doesn't do what it
expects code that is over complicated
you get the idea it's highly divergent
bad code doesn't look like other bad
code
so if you write higher quality code you
are not just making it you know writing
for your bugs but you're also helping
your colleagues to understand what is
going on not just because it's more
readable or whatever but because they've
seen code like that before
their pattern recognition can kick in
and instead of invoking slug Daniel
Kahneman calls system 2
where you actually have to you know use
your brain you can use your pattern
recognition system one highly efficient
or way faster and as long as the code is
offer good quality the pattern
recognition will mostly be correct it's
just when it kicks in for the bad code
then you have a problem but weirdly
that's also what machines need if I want
to analyze your code with its static
analysis with machine learning with
anything in between
it's very easier to analyze high quality
code if your data all flows through an
event sourcing layer the analysis is far
far easier than if you have SQL queries
all over your application if your
front-end uses like state management
libraries like such as redux or anything
elsewhere you have a concentrated place
where you work with pure functions to
iterate over data it's just a lot easier
to understand both for a human and for a
machine the my problem is the software
developers forget that they are
important and Ulrika talking about this
an hour ago so I hope you remember where
she said you your job is to puzzle out
what people mean right your job as a
software developer is to make sure that
the software does what people expect
your job is also to do it an ethical
manner and make sure everything is going
well but you know boil it down
you transform ideas into logic ideas are
vague they've missed our edge cases they
forget about things they're internally
inconsistent and your job is to Reason
through all of those things so I don't
really want you to spend time figuring
out why your infrastructure is broken
and by infrastructure I really do mean
anything that's not your domain I want
you to be figuring out the bugs in your
domain because those are way more
important that's what's going to lose
you money so I talked about what we're
up to I want to talk a little bit about
what you're going to be doing these are
things we seem to care about as software
developers we care about things like
cyclomatic complexity we use talling
like PMD to measure it we care about
things like test coverage these aren't
questions these are answers right and
they're fixed answers they don't get
better over time again we're stuck in
the 1990s maybe in the 2000s we didn't
have exceptions test in the 1990s at
least not by that name but what I really
care about is you know how do we measure
good design and I bet there's a better
answer than the cyclomatic complexity
not because it's a bad answer but
because it's one answer
and maybe it works for you and maybe it
doesn't like do I really care about test
coverage or do I care that my software
works we're so used to these tools that
kind of slap us on the rest and tell us
we're wrong and I'm really really
looking forward to the day where I'm
mobbing with my colleagues you know all
of us in front of a computer and the
computer is part of the mob not the
thing that we have to convince that our
ideas are worth having you know so I
really hope I've managed to convince you
to care about this that if any if
nothing else remember that you are
creative you're important you don't just
do what you like someone has told you to
implement in exactly the way they told
you to implement it I bet every single
one of you has had a conversation with
your technical and non-technical
colleagues where they try to tell you
not just that this thing needs
implementing or that this piece of logic
needs changing but also how to do it and
you have fought back and said I'm an
expert I know how to do this and if I
don't know I'm gonna go figure it out
you probably didn't get into this
industry to put brackets in the right
place at least I didn't I don't know
about you but I'm willing to bet that
you didn't you came here to solve
problems or to fix inefficiencies or to
democratize what we currently consider
luxuries you probably came into this
industry to understand the processes
behind all the ways in which we operate
as a society
you're here to improve the lives of
yourselves and others you know that's
what software developers do we don't
take what we have for granted we keep
and just assume that it's always going
to be that way you know we keep
improving we keep iterating except on
our own truly right the world is so much
better now that I can you know book a
restaurant on my phone or order a taxi
or get on with my life without having to
jump through the bureaucratic hoops I
used to but for some reason our software
developers we deal with those
bureaucratic hoops every day and we
don't even realize we're in this cage of
our own making so I would just like you
to be more human and I think being human
means teaching machine to do the
mechanical parts because after all we
are our choices that is the end of my
talk thank you very much for coming
I'm gonna find out what your question is
in one second but first I just want to
explain I have some links for you it's a
very top one is my Twitter noodle
sandwich calm is where you can find all
of the content for this talk of written
down because I cannot give a talk
without writing it down first Snoopy is
available on github and on NPM you can
run it please try it out and let me know
what you think you can tweet me alfie is
the products I showed third and toybox
is our demo environment for ml stuff in
which you can find the auto fix and the
type checker among other things if you
want to play around what was your
question sir hello hello oh cool sorry
we named our product after you but I
hope you don't mind is JavaScript the
language you focus on primarily I sure
could see char board on its Rosalind
library because it you can do a lot of
these things thing yeah I think so we
chose JavaScript for two maybe three
reasons and it's absolutely not the only
language we should be focusing on it's
just the language we started with the
reasons whether JavaScript tolling sucks
compared to what we're used to in the
worlds of dotnet and JVM is really like
it's good that it's not nearly as good
as what we're used to right I really
miss IntelliJ right and resharper like
if I had tools like that working in
JavaScript I would be a very very happy
individual so that's part of the reason
we picked it and we also picked it
because it's an entry language for a lot
of people so the help is like there's
more need for tools that help you and
not trying she linters I mean are great
but they also are painful and we just
wanted to help people a little bit we
actually started by trying to make
lenders more understanding of your
existing code and not give you the
feedback for example you know this line
is longer than 80 characters on every
single line and understand your code a
little bit before giving you that
feedback that's not ly started out and
we kind of shifted a few directions from
there but
it's part of the reason I encourage you
to go and try this floor thing because
well Rosalyn is amazing and if you you
have a great head start there you can go
and mine that code pretty quick any
other questions oh yeah okay cool
well if you have any questions you want
to ask me in private you can come grab
me you can I'm sure you'll be able to
find me and if you have any feedback
just come grab me or tweet me or email
me or whatever you want all right thank
you very much
[Music]